Olha só essa alerta urgente que acabou
de sair, que todo pai e toda mãe precisa
saber agora. Anvisa proibiu a venda e o
uso de vários lotes de fórmulas infantis
na anestr aqui no Brasil. Pois é,
estamos falando de produtos como
Nestogeno, Nan Supremipro, Nanlac e
alfamino. E o motivo, risco de
contaminação por uma toxina chamada
cereulide, produzida pela bactéria
bacilos cereus. E o pior, essa toxina
não é destruída quando você aquece o
leite para preparar a madeira. Veja bem,
se uma criança ingerir essa toxina, ela
pode apresentar vômitos, diarreia
intensa e até sonolência excessiva. Em
bebês pequenos, esses sintomas podem
evoluir rapidamente para desidratação e
complicações sérias. A Nestre já iniciou
um recal voluntário porque identificou
que o problema veio de uma matéria-pra
de um fornecedor internacional. Então
fica a orientação, confira agora o
número do lote na embalagem do produto
que você tem em casa e se estiver na
lista da Anvisa, suspenda o uso
imediatamente. Ч.